a former highschool cheerleader on trial
for killing her newborn baby was
recently acquitted of charges that
included aggravated murder Brooke
Skylar Richardson secretly gave birth at
her Ohio home and buried her daughter in
the backyard now she says the baby was
stillborn after a surprise verdict her
parents are now talking about the case
in their first television interview they
sat down with Aaron Moriarty's 48 hours
is there a way to describe this past
year the worst nightmare our lives have
been completely turned upside down the
lives of Kim and Scott Richardson
changed forever on July 14 2017 that's
when their 18 year old daughter admitted
to investigators she secretly gave birth
to a baby skylar told police the baby
was stillborn and that she buried the
infant in the backyard this is the
deeply poignant moment inside a police
interview room when Skylar's parents
learned the details for the first time
I've seen her every day look at her I
talked to her I hug her this is what
Skylar looked like at 3 months pregnant
again at seven and a half months and
then less than two days before giving
birth everything her parents say they
thought she simply looked healthy after
years of struggling with a debilitating
eating disorder 12 years old she
wouldn't buy gum because it had 5
calories I didn't even know gum had
calories how much do you think her
weight and eating ruled her life Oh 95
percent that is her life but Skylar
would rarely talk about it she's very
guarded keep a lot of Secrets yes but it
turned out there was one secret Skylar
couldn't keep after police got a tip
from her doctor Skylar was charged with
killing her baby the motive Warren
County Prosecuting Attorney David
Fornshell said motherhood didn't fit
into her life Skylar and her family were
pretty obsessed with external
appearances Kim and Scott Richardson
began the fight of their lives to save
their daughter from life in prison
there's no way she I would stake my life
on it
Erin Moriarty joins us life in prison
does seem very extreme under the
circumstance yes it can I just tell you
that these people really opened up their
lives to us most of the time there were
no attorneys there there were no limits
the kind of questions I could ask I
found them very credible very open and
one of the reasons why I wanted to get
this on the air is we really wanted to
give this family something that they
have not gotten up to now particularly
Skylar Richardson the presumption of
innocence looking at the case as it is
and it's a complicated case and it's an
emotional tough case yeah you do wonder
I mean everybody when is when they when
when you hear that someone didn't know
they were pregnant but you look at those
pictures and and you get it that's why
we put that because it's seven and a
half months she's wearing a two-piece
and her parents when you have someone
without eating disorder you're afraid to
talk about weight yeah and they didn't
want to keep bringing up they thought
she looked healthy one of the things
that really troubled me the most about
this case was this pretrial publicity it
was so negative it was so prejudicial it
was social media oh yes it was amplified
and was inaccurate the prosecuting
attorney went public with inflammatory
remarks that later turned out to be
totally wrong but then they were
amplified by social media these these
people have gotten death threats how
Scott are doing well she's doing better
than I mean what she was before she is
now enrolled in a new eating disorder
program she's working at the lawyer's
office where she has been working and
she's hoping to start college in January
all right Erin thank you they're in
Moriarty